tu as lu aujourd'hui je vous donne la
réponse de l'énigme d'hier vous allez me
détester je pense que vous allez
entendre la réponse si vous l'aviez pas
trouvé si vous n'avez pas regardé
l'énigme d'hier foncé la regarder tout
de suite avant de regarder la réponse
qui est maintenant la réponse à combien
de personnes vont à la plage et une
seule personne oui la personne qui va à
la plage les autres reviennent puisqu'il
est croiser en fait tout est dans le mot
croisés comme il croise toutes les
personnes que j'ai cités ça veut dire
que ces personnes là ne vont pas à la
plage mais qu'ils en reviennent
il est tout seul aller à la plage ne me
détester pas ne brûlez pas une énigme
aussi c'est fait pour ça pourra avoir un
angle de vue différent et peser le poids
de chaque mot et puis je suis sûr
qu'elle en a plein qui avait trouvé de
toute manière la solution ici c'est pas
le cas vous trouverez celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est parti pour l'énigme
du jour
énigme numéro 6 j'ai beaucoup trop
d'énergie quand je vous annonce les
numéros des lignes et en même temps je
me sois comme lui vous vous êtes
peut-être en train de profiter du soleil
et moi je suis dans mon bocal en train
de faire toutes ces vidéos
mais si vous avez suivi vous savez que
je triche je suis en ce moment en
vacances et j'ai tourné ces vidéos avant
l'été ou youtube space une énigme qui
est peut-être connu en tout cas c'est le
sentiment que j'ai parce que je la
connais depuis que j'ai tout petit mais
je voulais soumet aujourd'hui c'est
l'histoire d'un chasseur un chasseur qui
cherchent à tuer un ours c'est pas bien
je suis contre ça mais heureusement
c'est que dans l'énigme notre chasseur
repère un ours et ils veulent prendre
par surprise il veut le contourner mal
un autre chasseur notre chasseur par 10
km vers le sud donc il prend sa boussole
il va de 10 km vers le sud donc vers le
bas ensuite il fait 10 km vers l'est
toujours et que sa boussole il fait 10
km à pied vers l'est puis fait 10 km
vers le nord toujours axa boussole 10 km
vers le nord et se dit j'ai plus qu'à
changer une fois de direction et je suis
bon je l'aurais contourner mais une fois
qu'il a fini de marché ces 10 km vers le
nord il retombe nez à nez avec l'ours
l'ours qui n'a pas bougé de son
emplacement
c'est à dire que durant tout le trajet
du chasseur lourd s'est pas bougé d'un
centimètre
ma question est de quelle couleur et
l'ours vous l'attendiez pas celle là
alors c'est pas une blague c'est
vraiment la question de lening de quelle
couleur et l'ours ya une réponse très
logique pour connaître la couleur de
l'ours et surtout pour savoir expliquer
pourquoi lors sa cette couleur là vous
avez jusqu'à demain pour réfléchir
puisque dommage vous donnerai la réponse
si vous avez la réponse ne la mettez pas
dans les commentaires laissés les autres
chercher c'est beaucoup mieux par contre
dès que vous allez trouver ou si vous
connaissiez déjà l'énigme était un pouce
en l'air ce qui permettra de voir le
nombre de personnes qui ont résolu ce
mystère de l'ours de je sais pas quelle
couleur profiter du soleil profiter de
l'été n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chen avant de partir les rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao